well over a month into lockdown and
there are signs of frustration and
boredom on the streets now you drink you
know water the town center this is
Warsaw in the West Midlands and police
community support officers are trying to
stop her group from gathering in the
town center come on two meters and four
think a lockdown has never been simple
but these officers say it's getting more
difficult there are more people at bat
than there was lots of beginning and
depending on what dies on a working day
there are more people after the bats of
using the banks yeah yeah but if people
are to keep obeying lockdown
restrictions a professor who gives
evidence to the government's own
scientific advisors has told Sky News
the message needs to be clearer I
actually think it's very very difficult
when we're getting mixed messages from
the government on the one hand stay at
home on the other hand go into
non-essential work and I think this
urgent Lee needs to be dealt with the
government is sending out mixed messages
on the one hand telling people to stay
at home and on the other allowing
non-essential work to take place the
government's message has been clear and
consistent from day one about staying at
home obviously to protect the NHS and to
save lives but we've also been clear
about people going to work that if you
can't work from home through social
distancing the measures that are
actually in place in some workplaces now
that you can go to work the government
says the number of vehicles on the roads
is starting to rise one taxi driver we
spoke to says he's making more journeys
because custom is slowly going up how
many more people are you seeing out and
about five to ten percent it's my
opinion the way that is good yeah and
they are Boris Vilas takes long I mean
knock down that's why yeah the argument
is the sooner you start a lockdown
the sooner people will become bored with
it as things stand Vista
just under two more weeks until the
government officially reviews its locked
down rules traffic on the m6 in
Birmingham it's nothing like a rush hour
but there's growing concern about
people's reasons for traveling visa
Holland
Sky News Birmingham